son ya más de 170 casos vinculados al
foco de nanjing en la provincia oriental
de jiangxi en la que es la peor crisis
que sufre china en los últimos meses el
rebrote nació en el personal de limpieza
del aeropuerto que queda infectado muy
probablemente al operar en algún vuelo
llegado del extranjero de ahí pasó a
colegas y familiares y se han detectado
casos en al menos ya cuatro provincias y
en pekín que rompe así una racha en
blanco de seis meses
nanjing ha decretado ya el protocolo
habitual en estos casos ha emprendido
una campaña de test masivos sobre sus
casi diez millones de habitantes ha
cerrado varios restaurantes y gimnasios
y ha restringido movimientos no habrá
vuelos en dos semanas y han quedado
cancelados los autobuses de larga
distancia detrás del último rebrote está
la nueva variante del está mucho más
mortal y contagiosa china está inquieta
por esta variante porque hay dudas
razonables sobre la eficacia de sus
vacunas sobre todo después de las crisis
de tailandia e indonesia muchas de las
personas de nanjing de hecho quedaron
infectadas después de haber recibido sus
dos dosis aunque
afortunadamente no han desarrollado
síntomas severos